في جميع انحاء العالم يبلغ معدل البقاء
على قيد الحياه بعد عام واحد من زراعه
القلب نحو 90 بالمئه وحوالي 80% بعد خمس
سنوات واليكم بعض المحطات المهمه حول
زراعه القلب اول عمليه زرع قلب بشري
الانسان اجريت في مستشفى في جنوب افريقيا
وذلك عام
1967 لكنه توفي بعد 18 عاما بسبب التهاب
الرئوي وليس لعطلان في القلب المزروع عام
1984 كانت الطفل الامريكيه ستيفاني فاي
اول رضيع يختار جراحته زراعه قلب غير بشري
حيث تلقى صدرها قلب قرد وعاشت ل 20 يوما
بعد ذلك
سينزل من بريطانيا احتفلت باربعين عاما من
الحياه بعد زراعه القلب في اواخر العام
الماضي المثير انها اجرد زراعه قلب اخرى
عام 2005 عندما اصاب الضعف قلبها الاول
في اول العام الماضي تمكن جراحون امريكيون
من زراعه قلب خنزير معدل براثيا في صدر
مريض البشري في اول عمليه من نوعها لكن
المريض توفي بعد شهرين من العمليه